Це один з видів зброї, яку хотіла б отримати Україна від Німеччини.
Протикорабельні ракети типу "морський спис". За даними впливової німецької газети Frankfurter Allgemeine,
ці боєприпаси містяться у переліку замовлень, які Київ скерував до Берліна у квітні.
Йдеться здебільшого про системи для захисту чорноморського узбережжя
від російського вторгнення. Чому Україна просить допомоги у західних союзників
для розбудови свого військово-морського потенціалу, для німецьких експертів очевидно.
Треба казати відверто: в української армії безнадійна ситуація на морі та у повітрі.
В українців нині лише 125 боєздатних військових літаків
на противагу 1160 по інший бік.
Ситуація ще гірша у військово-морських силах. Оскільки ми знаємо, що український флот
практично було знищено незаконною окупацією та анексією Криму.
Україні залишився лише один великий військовий корабель - фрегат "Гетьман Сагайдачний",
якого просто не було у порту приписки на момент окупації Криму.
З тих пір Україна намагається з нуля розбудувати свої військово-морські сили.
В Україні немає значної кількості навіть патрульних човнів, щоб просто захищати
свої територіальні води. І, звичайно, будувати флот - це надзвичайно дорого.
Наразі, на відміну від Сполучених Штатів Америки, Німеччина не постачає до України
жодних видів військової зброї. Як, втім, і до Росії.
Щодо Москви з 2014 року діє абсолютне ембарго, обумовлене європейськими санкціями.
Ще у 2014 році з Німеччини до України експортували бронежилети та шоломи
на загальну суму 25 мільйонів євро. А у 2015-му німці надали генератори струму
для корветів та мультисенсорну платформу для спостереження за морем
на загальну суму 5 мільйонів євро. Відтоді товари військового призначення
більше не постачаються. З Німеччини до України надходять винятково спортивні та мисливські рушниці.
Цікаво, що з 2014 до 2019 року найбільшим постачальником озброєнь в Україну
була Чехія, звідки ЗСУ отримали десятки вживаних бронемашин.
Берлін же не лише не постачає техніку, бронежилети або оптичні прилади,
а й не надає своїх військових інструкторів, як це, приміром,  роблять США, Великобританія та Польща.
Водночас Німеччина неодноразово приймала на лікування і реабілітацію
поранених українських вояків та - найголовніше - усіляко підтримує Україну дипломатичним шляхом.
Військову допомогу ФРН не надає зокрема і з міркувань зовнішньої політики,
зміцнюючи цим свої можливості як одного з ключових посередників
у врегулюванні конфлікту на Сході України.
Німецькі журналісти з’ясували, що Київ у минулому вже безуспішно просив
у Берліна вживані військові кораблі - корвети. За даними інформованих джерел в Києві та Берліні,
міністр закордонних справ ФРН Гайко Маас досі чинив опір.
Водночас міністерка оборони Аннеґрет Крамп-Карренбауер була у цьому питанні "відкритою".
І щодо актуального українського запиту, за твердженням джерел, вона теж була "за".
Керівниця оборонного відомства прямо каже, що Росія вже конкретно і безпосередньо загрожує Європі.
Дії Росії, на жаль, не спрямовані на створення відносин довіри.
Вони свідомо і цілеспрямовано провокують. Я дуже дякую нашим українським друзям за те,
що досі вони реагували на це дуже виважено.
Оскільки ми хочемо спільно з Україною не піддаватись на ці російські ігри.
Не лише окремі політики у правлячій коаліції висловлюються
за поставки оборонних товарів союзниці Україні. Навіть серед Зелених у Берліні,
традиційно однієї з найбільш пацифістських політичних сил, є розуміння
побажань України щодо озброєнь. На парламентських виборах восени Зелені мають шанси
прийти до влади в ФРН. Колишня "зелена" євродепутатка Ребекка Гармс упевнена,
що Німеччині треба посилити підтримку України.
Щодо озброєння, то це завжди було важкою темою для моєї партії. Але для мене це серйозно.
Україна має право оборонятися та захищати свій суверенітет.
З точки зору озброєнь, це Давид проти Голіафа. І, попри це, ми, Німеччина, не допомагаємо.
Це не є доброю позицією.
Я вважаю, що перелік оборонних озброєнь, який Україна надала своїм партнерам
включно з Німеччиною, це важливий перелік. І якщо ми хочемо, щоб Україна
в майбутньому почувалась упевнено і путінська гра м'язами не заганяла її у пастку провокацій,
тоді потрібно абсолютно серйозно розглянути можливість, як нам краще озброїти Україну.
Однак у Бундестазі та уряді більше тих, хто або категорично засуджує будь-які поставки зброї Києву
(як-то Ліві та "Альтернатива для Німеччини"), або каже, що цю опцію варто розглядати
у разі нового ескалаційного кроку з боку Росії.
Експерти схиляються до думки, що наразі немає жодних шансів отримати схвалення німецьких політиків,
особливо з огляду на те, що всі зосередилися на вибори до Бундестагу.
Українська дипломатія у цілому стала останнім часом більш атакувальною.
Київ зробив одночасно низку вимогливих прохань і до Вашингтона, і до європейських країн.
Запит на вступ до НАТО, на ракети "Петріот", дискусії щодо відновлення ядерного статусу.
Прохання до Берліна, схоже, із цієї ж серії. Розрахунок: чим більше просиш, тим більше отримаєш.
Запит - це вже форма створення тиску, вказування, мовляв, ось те, що нам буде потрібно.
І у багатьох випадках країни просять значно більше, аби отримати хоча б щось.
Доволі ймовірно, що це є частиною стратегії Києва. Усі знають, наскільки малоймовірно,
що Німеччина надасть Києву озброєння. Хоча, хто знає. А раптом Німеччина надасть щось інше.
Оглядачі упевнені: рішення щодо відвідення військ Москва ухвалила не просто так.
Ймовірно, за лаштунками їй були запропоновані певні поступки за те, що вона, так би мовити, "заспокоїться".
Експерти припускають, що одним з кроків назустріч Кремлю з боку Берліна
могла бути обіцянка зменшення напруги довкола будівництва "Північного потоку-2".
Не виключено, що на негласні поступки могла піти й влада України.
Київ у цьому контексті міг зажадати від Заходу також певних конкретних компенсацій.
Наприклад, у економічній сфері. І, ймовірно, про них стане відомо найближчим часом.
Європарламент тим часом не виключає у майбутньому вторгнення російських військ в Україну.
Реагуючи на широкомасштабні військові навчання Росії в Криму та біля східного кордону України,
29 квітня євродепутати ухвалили дуже жорстку резолюцію, у якій в тому числі є заклик
надати Україні оборонні озброєння.
Європарламент також закликав ЄС показати Москві, що ціна можливого вторгнення
в Україну буде високою. Він запропонував серед інших штрафних заходів
негайно зупинити імпорт російської нафти і газу.